U.S and South Korean war planes carrying
out a highly visible response to
Saturday's missile launch by North Korea
South Korea's defense Ministry said the
drills headed by nuclear-capable
American B-1 bombers affirmed the United
States commitment to the extended
deterrence of its nuclear weapons
the U.S and Japan held a similar
separate exercise over Waters off
Japan's West Coast where the missile
fired on Saturday came down
North Korea State media agency says
Crews were given no early warning ahead
of the order to launch the pasong-15
intercontinental ballistic missile proof
it says of capability to deliver quote
fatal nuclear counter-attack
after the latest launch Kim yo Jong the
sister of North Korea's leader said
whether to use the Pacific Ocean as its
shooting range depends on the United
States
North Korea is not happy with the
ramping up of uh military exercises
between the U.S and South Korea which
will take place in March there's also a
tabletop exercise that will look at
nuclear scenarios that will happen
between the U.S and South Korea next
week and I think North Korea is sending
a message that it is unhappy with that
and it will uh Fight Fire with Fire
while Saturday's launch still took some
hours between order and ignition North
Korea continues to work on a solid fuel
rocket that takes less time to prepare
years of diplomacy sanctions and
international censure have done little
to slow its progress
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera